What niches are you still hitting during the winter? All of them. All the ones I've been hitting,
I'm going to keep hitting. All of them. Literally every single niche. Now, am I going to be a little
bit more strategic about the cities I'm in? I have to be. I have to be more strategic because
some of these cities, these business owners pack up shop. I know I had this site in New York,
some cities like Rochester had a tree service site. I found out pretty quickly that they just
shut it down for the winter. Just shut it down. In fact, what they do is in the winter, they actually
just do snow plowing. They do snow removal. They don't even do tree service. They're like,
yeah, we're shutting it down November 15th and we're going to do snow plowing. We'll call you
in March. No and ifs or buts about it. They just don't do it. I still do the same niches. I just
get a lot smarter about what cities. Okay.